the the film captures the the the tenor
and the atmosphere of of an impending
attack and and and um I I I mean the
only thing that I can really compare it
to is uh is is is Restrepo is another
documentary that I love so much and that
that that going through the reality of
that through through W with with Marines
and with the military this does it on a
civilian level and on a political level
for what these how these people bonded
how
they and a lot of that came down to sort
of the timing of of of the entire
project can you just kind of walk us
through what this thing set out to be
and then what it turned into yeah yeah
by the way these are fantastic this is
and if you the smoke bothers you too
much you can just do that and it blows
it away um this for the camera this is
for a camera right no I use it for even
you know just to clean up because CLE
yeah I'm a little OCD on there that
that's why I got those minivac over
there um so
yeah so we it was it was in this room my
friend I had a friend Billy Smith who
produced this with
me and Billy and I Billy's an actor you
know him yeah yeah and I had not ever
met him I didn't know who he was we met
at the uh CGI he was a cop right wasn't
he a cop he was a cop I met him like way
back in the day he was so good to me man
one of my first Gates dude he's a
fantastic guy yeah he he he was a a a
Boston PD cop he was a un police officer
who posted in a few different countries
and and an actor throughout and a and a
marine uh he was you know station out of
Kuwait in the first golf War but always
an actor had even even when he was you
know a cop he would get ragged by his
fellow cops for going off and doing that
pansy thing he was doing or whatever I I
know that theater groups and and um and
we met at the at the CGI in New York
when he had made a do an interesting
documentary about
Pakistan and I was starting to think
about making documentaries a little bit
we talked we became friends and so then
we set off to make a couple that didn't
happen I went down to Syria a couple
times during the war and uh met Assad
and had the idea that we would do this
uh documentary about how is he still
standing five years after the Arab
Spring and then we'll go talk to the
Russians and the United States and the
jordanians the Lebanese we'll get we try
to get how is how did this guy manage
after everybody said he he was counted
out
right and I am not saying this in a
celebratory way uh but I was going to
approach it very we'll see what what
comes and at first Assad was extremely
open and uh he he you know certainly
knew how to talk to um a Westerner who's
coming over to make a documentary and
say things that
would sound very rational so
on and bit by bit it closed down uh you
know the well we did say you could talk
to some Isis uh prisoners and but now
you can't or you or we did say you could
talk to the former opposition press
because with the war there were no
opposition
press we did say that you could you know
not have a minder and go talk to whoever
you want on the street but now let's say
you can't do those things let's see what
else you can do and we walked away from
it I I didn't feel that I was the guy to
do that documentary that investigative
journalist one where you're told no by
everything and you keep going I wanted
to see if I could do you know the trust
one yeah yeah and uh I just felt that's
where I would have something a value
added and when I saw I couldn't really
get it and I don't know if if it was him
or or his Gatekeepers but it got shut
down so then we had tried on another one
about kosi and while we were in
Istanbul uh we found out there was
another filmmaker already doing it very
well financed very good filmmaker and
our interest was that the film a film on
could showed you get done and we thought
that you know that guy's got it so we
left that one we're kind of looking for
and I obviously we were attracted to
where maybe my access could get us in on
one of the more urgent stories in the
world now we here in America hear about
um you know a bad phone call between our
president uh Donald Trump
and uh the president of Ukraine yeah and
you know you you have more Regional uh
experience have lived in Russia and so
on but I I knew very little about
Ukraine and but I I had been intrigued
about this this comedic actor who you
know played a teacher who gets suddenly
a right in candidate becomes the
president and he's got a successful show
you know it's the comedic westwing he's
Martin Sheen yeah and then he runs for
the real presidency and wins it would be
Martin sheena's president [__]
Wild wouldn't necessarily be a bad thing
either um so Barton Sheen I mean
generically but so this is long before
the the the Russian
buildup uh this pre-co and Billy came to
me with the idea because he had contact
his zinsky he met somebody knew him and
I said that might be that might be fun
you know getting ourselves in all this
heavy stuff and you know running into
doors and this light-hearted Whimsical
tale of this
actor so we started pursuing it and then
then Co happened and we were delayed and
over Co we I got to meet president
zinski over
Zoom um very engaging guy
uh and sort of told him what I'd like to
do and it comes down to this what kind
of documentary can I offer that's going
to be you know have a place with all the
great documentarians out there and doing
things why getting the way uh and it was
going to be if I could create I don't
know some kind of a special uh cander or
trust and and and have an unguarded this
personal not not a Barbara Walter's sort
of personal but you know a Vibe sure and
I also noted that you know he he he
spoke better English than he thought he
did and I I thought it would be great to
share this guy with America and that it
might be good to try to get him to speak
English in this
thing um conversations would flow better
also because I wouldn't be going through
the translator
so by the time we actually got to see
him because it was
not um I don't think that I was
motivated enough to go and spend 14 days
in a hotel room to maybe see him right
uh and and we we just put it off till
the co thing ended by the time we got
there by the time we could sort of get
everything back going is November
2021 and yes the buildup head was was in
the news it was
simmering there were about I think 75
85,000 troops um Russian troops uh at
the border some equipment
moving but as we know within I don't
know a month of that it was nearly
200,000 troops and you know the whole
nine yards
and um so we we went to see him in
November and that did not work out
because some there was a very very
intricate intricate um um operation to
capture just in a sting operation to
capture by name by face the guys the
Vagner group guys who had brought down
that airliner uh a couple years earlier
yeah and when we got there in November
just as they were going to NAB them and
it's all open source to read about what
they did it's really interesting led by
Ukrainian intelligence but I think with
help from our guys in
UK um and uh there was a leak and they
they they all
scattered and there was some suspicion
that it was someone in the president's
office so they were under crisis
management man agement and couldn't see
us so we went picked up the culture a
little bit we went out to the to marle
front lines of you know the
existing problems since
2014 and um you know took it all in met
with a lot of different kinds of
people by the time we were able to come
back and to be told that if you can come
and stay a weake the president will find
a time to see you great let's go that
was
February
2022 so we we're there and we we're
being patient with it you know we know
we're confident he's going to see
us but by the time I was leaving um
there was already the maximum travel
advisory in place you know it was hot uh
in fact they were saying it's going to
happen tomorrow for about a week and a
half and tomorrow would come come and
tomorrow would go you you didn't see it
happening I started out not believing it
was going to happen I I was still in
February early February I was
absolutely I understood that that all
Intel you know that whe you wherever you
were hearing
it were believing it was happen but
there were a couple of key people who
knew the region really well
who like me
felt uh there's no upside in this for
Putin you know you're just gonna you
break it you buy it you're G to have i'
gotten to know Ukraine well enough they
were they were gonna they were GNA fight
they would they would all be willing to
die before they' let this happen and and
that would be true if the Russian
invasion had succeeded uh in February
did you have a sense of that on the
ground I mean could you feel that
already 100 right 100% like like nothing
I'd ever part of what we were talking
about earlier his Unity thing was they
all had a red cape on him in my view
they just ready to you go and within
that which is a really important thing I
have a blanket around here somewhere
from the railroad there the Ukrainian
railroad motto is iron and soft and it's
exactly the to me the seryan
piece to the iron you have to maintain
your humanity and you've got to laugh
and sing and you know they there's so
many touching stories of
how gentle Warriors but man Warriors is
in block
[Music]
letters